cela fait longtemps que les 408
n'offrent plus 4 108 logements ni même
550 comme au début des années 80
aujourd'hui une quinzaine de familles
vivent encore dans la dernière barre en
attente d'être relogés un bâtiment
promis à la démolition dès l'année
prochaine tout comme celui ci qui abrite
la chaufferie ça se voit quand même
l'évolution c'est sacré coup de vieux là
il faut casser ça rien non c'est pas
bien pour mon image
il y a deux ans les ouvriers commencé un
long grignotage des bâtiments fenêtres
par fenêtre
la fin d'une époque un choc aussi pour
les habitants les enfants qui n'ont pas
la mémoire courte vivaient un premier
confinement avant l'heure est à 20
pouces hier et on n'avait pas le droit
d'aller sur la place on rester chez nous
pour trois logements détruits
un seul sera reconstruit une
reconstruction qui ne devrait pas
commencer avant 2030
la nouvelle maire de besançon a sa
propre vision
mais elle veut surtout accélérer le
tempo on a vu un certain nombre de plans
déjà mais qui sont révisés encore une
fois à travers ce qui vient de se passer
par un bloco vite et moi je pense que la
présence de jardin doit s'inscrire
maintenant dans tous les quartiers chez
un petit peu impatiente mais gérer dire
mon impatience à l'état on discutera
avec la réduction éventuelle du chantier
dévêtent dans un autre quartier pousse
sans doute la nouvelle élue à accélérer
quel habitat sous quelle forme
là encore les enfants ne manquent pas
d'idées un parc aquatique
plus beau plus généreux plus clair les
couleurs sont claires pas son gros
marron comme ça le chantier des 408
coûtera 26 millions d'euros
il faudra aussi un jour songé un nouveau
nom pour le quartier